die gefahr eines atomkrieges ist real
innerhalb von sekunden kann als leicht
falsch interpretiert das eigentlich
harmloses ereignis zum auslöser einer
atomkatastrophe werden manche länder wie
nordkorea versuchen sie sogar zu
provozieren doch nicht nur die direkte
zerstörung durch die atomwaffen selbst
und ihre radioaktive strahlung die
unzählige menschenleben kosten würden
wäre die eigentliche katastrophe eines
atomkrieges die wirkliche katastrophe
eines atomaren schlagabtausches wäre
eine andere was genau wohl mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit das gesamte leben wie
wir es bisher kennen auf dieser welt
aufrücken würde erfahrt ihr jetzt bei
klick zum fixen herzlich willkommen
august 145 zwei atombomben lösen jeweils
eine riesige druckwelle aus die
innerhalb von sekunden die japanischen
städte hiroshima und nagasaki und ihre
umgebung dem erdboden gleichmachen
zehntausende menschen verbrennen so
unvorstellbar tragisch die konsequenten
der beiden atombomben von 125 waren umso
tragischer ist dass die heutigen
atomwaffen sogar noch einmal deutlich
gefährlicher sind als die atombomben von
hiroshima und nagasaki und schon diese
atombomben haben damals knapp eine
viertelmillion menschen getötet wie
müssen wir uns also das szenario
vorstellen wenn die welt jetzt in einen
atomkrieg schlittern würde die genauen
ausmaße kommen natürlich auch die menge
der eingesetzten waffen an
ich lege euch die fakten etwa auf den
tisch und das nicht weil ich euch angst
machen will
danke übrigens an dieser stelle an hart
walker von dem der vorschlag für dieses
thema kommt die erste reaktion bei
solchen themen ist menschlicher natur
augen und ohren zu und raus damit aus
meinen gedanken wenn die bilder im kopf
tatsächlich komme aus zu halten doch
findet ihr es nicht alarmierend dass die
meisten männer die über die macht von
atomwaffen verfügen im grunde auch
bereit sind diese im ernstfall
einzusetzen und dafür mich wenige
weltweit gibt es schätzungsweise etwa
10.000 atomsprengköpfe jede einzelne
davon anlage etwa 100.000 menschen auf
einen schlag zu töten
sie töten einfach alles und werden
deswegen von der
nichtregierungsorganisation icann
internationale kampagne zur abschaffung
von atomwaffen auch als verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit eingeschätzt um es
noch einmal klipp und klar auf den punkt
zu bringen
das heutige waffenarsenal reicht
tatsächlich aus um einen mehrfachen um
wackel auszulösen
also die mehrfache zerstörung unseres
planeten und nahezu sämtlichen leben so
jetzt bitte nicht 14.000 bei 100.000
rechnen das wäre nämlich eine
milchmädchenrechnung
und dass ich nun plötzlich irgendeiner
atommacht auf dieser welt weise
nordkorea russland die usa pakistan oder
indien dazu entscheidend atomwaffen
einzusetzen das ist nicht weit hergeholt
bereich nur ein falsch interpretiert es
eigentlich harmlose ereignis ein
unbedachtes wort zur falschen zeit oder
eben auch einen aufbrausenden charakters
bedauerlicherweise aber einen mächtigen
posten an der spitze eines landes
innerhalb gehen wir zunächst mal von
einer einzigen atombombe aus die über
einer stadt wie berlin gezündet wurde
eine trident rakete mit einer
sprengkraft von 455 kilotonnen
zum vergleich die hiroshima bombe hatte
eine von 15 kilotonnen
der feuerball hätte einen durchmesser
von etwa 18 kilometer jedes lebewesen
was ich in einem radius von acht
kilometern befindet würde verbrennungen
dritten grades erleiden also eigentlich
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit tödlich auf
einer fläche von 16.000 quadratkilometer
an gebe es radioaktiven niederschlag
etwa 230.000 menschen würden sofort
sterben etwas mehr als 50.000 würden
verletzt sei dies hätte zum einen die
ausgelöste druckwelle der bombe selbst
zum anderen aber auch die enorme
radioaktive strahlung zu verantworten
doch die sind wohl nicht die einzigen
möglichst tragischen konsequenzen eines
atomwaffeneinsatzes vor allem wenn es
mehrere atomexplosion wind ein
wissenschaftlerteam aus new jersey hat
mit hilfe von modernen klima
simulationsprogrammen herausgefunden
dass eine weltweite atomare eskalation
unser weltklima völlig aus dem
gleichgewicht bringen würde
das so die forscherinnen forscher sei
die wahre katastrophe an der atomaren
eskalation die explosion der atombombe
hätte zur folge dass riesige mengen an
staub aufgewirbelt werden
diese würden durch die unvorstellbare
hitze genau wie die asche die durch die
brände entsteht bis zur 80 kilometer
hoch in die mittlere und hohe
stratosphäre gelangen bedingt dadurch
dass die partikel doch mehrere jahre
bleiben würde so das forscherteam würde
kaum mehr sonderlich zur erde gelangen
der sogenannte nukleare winter liege die
durchschnittstemperatur auf der erde um
bis zu 8 grad celsius sinken das wäre
tatsächlich eiszeit niveau die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus new jersey sind sich sicher dass
dies auch in regionen auf der erde die
weitab vom ort des atom skifliegen große
klimatische konsequenzen zur folge
hätten vor allem das erste jahr so sagen
die forscherinnen und forscher würde
besonders schlimm werden die extreme
kälte
diesen boden gefrieren und pflanzen
sterben die melodie
weltgesundheitsorganisation schätzt dass
mit den weltweiten getreidevorräte etwa
80 tage lang die komplette
weltbevölkerung ernährt werden könnte
doch dann ist schluss eine weltweite
hungerkatastrophe würde seinen lauf
nimmt und nicht nur die extreme kälte
sondern auch die uv strahlung die nun
durch die zerstörte ozonschicht fast
ungefiltert auf die erde treffen wird
und zwar im nachgang wenn der staub sich
gelegt hat nach einigen jahren würde die
noch wenigen pflanzen eingehen lassen
das resultat die ernte viele aus und
wohl die meisten die nicht sowieso schon
durch die druckwellen der atombomben das
feuer oder die strahlung ihr leben
verloren hätten wären spätestens dann in
diesem szenario verhungern nicht zu
vergessen auch das soziale chaos am
anfang des films dass wir relativ
schnell ausbrechen würde und das
überleben für jeden einzelnen von uns zu
einem wahrhaftigen kampf machen würde
katastrophen wie der hurrikan katrina
haben gezeigt dass menschen die in ihrer
existenz bedroht sind zu allem bereit in
die zivilisation würde sofort
zusammenbrechen denn dann lautet das
motto wohl jeder kämpft für sich das
forscherteam aus new jersey war übrigens
selbst überrascht von ihren ergebnissen
verwundert zeigen nämlich vor allem
darüber dass auch wenige waffen mit
einer eher geringe sprengkraft große
globale folgen haben könnten
ihren berechnungen zufolge seien diese
in der lage pro kilotonne sprengkraft
mehr opfer und rauch zu verursachen als
diejenigen atombomben mit großer
sprengkraft es liegt allerdings auf
szenarien nach denen menschen in
bestimmten regionen der welt einen
atomkrieg überleben könnten nämlich in
den gebieten in denen die temperatur
etwas weniger wind den
simulationsrechnungen zufolge wäre dies
in der äquatorregion und an der
südspitze von südamerika und in
australien der fall
eventuell könnten einige pflanzen
insekten und fische die dunkelheit und
die starke uv-strahlung aushalten und
somit den menschen als nahrungsgrundlage
dient es ist also
ein ziemlich düsteres bild im wahrsten
sinne des wortes dass ich hier aufzeigen
musste sollte uns eine warnung sein und
wir sollten wirklich alles
menschenmögliche tun um dieses szenario
zu verhindern ein atomkrieg wird einzig
und allein zu einem furchtbaren ende für
wahrscheinlich alle menschen ich möchte
uns hoffentlich nicht mehr über dieses
thema berichten wenn ihr mehr über
andere interessante themen erfahren wird
dadurch mehr hier ein abo auf und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit
dunkle materie rente glücksspiel
schwarze löcher eine rolle
das war ziemlich spannend also am besten
drauf klicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt